I'm joined today by Steven Clifford who
served as CEO for King Broadcasting
Company and national mobile television
he's been a director of 13 companies and
has chaired the Compensation Committee
for both public and private companies he
has a BA from Columbia University and an
MBA from Harvard Business School we are
talking about CEO pay today and this is
a very interesting issue because it
relates to the conversation around
inequality it relates to the
conversation about wages that's going on
in the United States so maybe to start
us off
how has CEO compensation changed over
the last several decades and how do we
measure that well in real dollars CEOs
and when I'm talking about CEOs I'm
talking about their fortune 500 CEOs
they've got had a thousand percent
increase a tenfold increase one way and
by the way the average worker has got
virtually nothing Oh since 1980 one way
to measure this is the multiple of the
CEOs pay with the median employee of the
company in 1980 in 1978 that number was
28 CEO making 28 times what the average
worker made today that number is
somewhere between 300 and 700 depending
on how you count it there's so many
different ways that CEOs make money to
give you a couple of comparisons or one
comparison in Japan today that number 16
so you know either CEOs today or 20
times more valuable than they were a few
decades ago or 30 times better than the
Japanese or something's gone terribly
wrong and talk a little bit about how
these compensation committees work this
is something I've read quite a bit about
talked about the role that a
compensation committee has in
determining CEO pay and and what's
really interesting to me is how there's
this sort of closed loop that allows the
neverending increase of CEO compensation
effectively with no consequences
yes they
every board has usually a three member
Compensation Committee these people are
not experts in compensation they're
normally executives often CEOs
themselves or ex-ceo the board always
accepts the Compensation Committee's
recommendation for compensation Warren
Buffett said in all of his years on
boards he'd never heard of a board
rejecting the compensation committee's
report the Compensation Committee and
the whole system depends on compensation
consultants and the compensation
consultants have structured a highly
complex system for rewarding CEOs by the
way this system has absolutely nothing
to do with a market CEOs are very
different than LeBron James LeBron James
skills are portable he can take his
skills and improve any basketball team
tomorrow CEO skills tend to be industry
specific and company specific to be an
effective CEO you have to know a whole
lot about a single company is history
its culture its finances its marketing
its IT its patents etc etc that
knowledge isn't worth much outside that
company so companies don't bid against
each other for CEOs less than 2% of the
Fortune 500 CEOs will previously CEO at
another public company 75% of all CEOs
are internal promotion so there's no
market for CEOs so lacking a market what
the sultan's do is they say first we'll
see what other CEOs are being paid and
will your patient be based on what other
CEOs this is called the appeard company
selects its own people surprise surprise
every peer group is filled with very
highly paid CEOs so the first step in
the process is
semble a peer group of very highly paid
CEOs
second step in the process is decide
where you belong so each company says
we're not an average company we
shouldn't be paying the average of our
peer group we're a good company so we
should pay at the 75th percentile so all
CEOs live in live in Lake Wobegon
they're all about that hmm then you get
a target let's say that target comes out
to say 15 million well then the real
basis of this thing is supposedly
pay-for-performance so the CEO on the
comp committee negotiates some kind of
performance metrics if the CEO beats
those metrics he makes 30 million 40
million hmm
now there's clarity of this is that 40
million goes back into the peer group of
all of these other peers they get rain
is it because he made 40 million he gets
raises because they made raises so you
have this endless line of CEOs playing
compensation yeah it's a never-ending
feedback loop effectively so what are
the economic consequences of this I mean
there will be some people who will hear
this conversation you know they'll say
yeah you know it sounds like that that
multiplier between the CEO pay and the
average or even lowest worker pay at
that same company it's huge but we're
talking about one CEO and then yes
you've got all the vice presidents but
they're making significantly less than
the than the CEO even though there's
more of them and in total the
compensation is not that out of whack
what what are the economic impacts of
this level of inequality well the the
amount the companies waste on executive
pay is as you say not significant in
these billion-dollar corporations
the biggest problem that the bigger
problems are the decisions that it leads
into and the effect of this on company
morale
I mean company morale gets pretty
miserable when the boss is making seven
hundred times what you're making but
more importantly it leads companies to
buy back their own stocks to keep the
stock price high because a high stock
price is often a bonus simple metric and
85% of a CEO pay comes in equity of one
form or another so
CEO is highly motivated to keep the
stock right sorry night you can do this
through the hard work of developing
better products and cutting costs and
what not or the easy work of just buying
back your own stuff so in the last 10
years the S&P 500 has spent four
trillion dollars buying back its own
stock as 50% more than they paid out in
dividends and that's half of their net
earnings now at the same time if they
were by doing this and this is for 4
billion that should have been invested
in product development research and
development worker training plant and
equipment but at the same time they were
buying back their stock for 43 and they
were cutting R&D by by 50% and cutting
investment in plan equipment by 50% so
basically American industries eating its
own seed core because the way it pays
its CEOs well there's that aspect you
know there's also the aspect of even
thinking about it from a sort of micro
economic perspective if you take a 15
dollar a 15 million dollar bonus if you
imagine giving that to the CEO the CEO
doesn't really need that money to
maintain a stable standard of living so
a lot of that money is not going to be
put into economically stimulative areas
whereas if you take that 15 million and
distributed amongst low earners in that
company you're earning $30,000 and you
get an extra $2,000 you're spending most
of that money at businesses at a much
higher economic multiplier absolutely
absolutely I mean there there is a limit
to the number of yachts you can buy so
that money does not go does not get
spent it would get spent if it were
given to the workers and I you know the
most probably the worst economic
consequence for the country is the great
increase in economic inequality it is
really spurred by CEO pay oh you say
well it's only you know you're only
talking about 500 CEOs or whatnot but
that what they get paid influences
really what the 1% gets paid I mean if
you look at the top one-tenth of 1% who
took 40 percent of all economic gains
over the last 30 years about 70% of them
are business executives so the people
that are getting huge huge incomes today
it's not basketball players and it's not
actresses and it's not heiresses it's
business executives as I said 70% of
them are business objective they are
highly influenced by what CEOs make and
this has caused basically being 1% to
get all of the economic gains and the
average worker to get nothing absolutely
and that's something we've been covering
for a very very long time but we've been
speaking with Steven Clifford a really
important topic because of what it
represents in the broader growth in
inequality and are in our economy thanks
so much for talking to me about it
sure thanks for having